hi quick take welcome to our live q a on
the post
lock down world i'm karina mori in tokyo
as the number of kogit 19 cases appeared
to level out in some parts of the world
lockdowns have started to ease but
questions do remain about what the
so-called new normal will
really look like day to day so to answer
that and more let me now introduce you
to our guests
we have brothers stefan heikovich senior
principal scientist
strategy and foresight and director of
csiro data61 insights
and crispin heikovich director of the
infectious diseases unit at australia's
largest hospital
and senior lecturer at the university of
queensland both joining us
from brisbane and of course bloomberg
news health editor
jason gail from melbourne so nice to
have you all
and we have siblings today
welcome thanks for joining us so stefan
and chrisman who's the older brother
can you guess jason what do you think
thanks guys
don't ask me who the tallest one is
so you're both in sciences with a career
in science
how did that childhood have anything to
do with that
might help our dad was a physicist so
upper atmosphere physics he did
so that probably rubbed off on us a bit
yeah
i'm the only member of the family who
doesn't have a phd i'm a medical doctor
so
is there some sibling rivalry here
i'm so far ahead it's not really rivalry
we just you know
you've already won
a little bit of rivalry you know luckily
you got us on a video link
is it just youtube brothers or do you
have other siblings
oh we should have invited him on yeah
yeah
next time okay well we're really happy
to have you both on and
for everybody watching us please ask us
your questions live and i'll do my best
to get them answered throughout this
broadcast so
something i want to touch on before we
get started though is something we can't
ignore right now or the u.s
protests going on um how does that
relate to the spread of coven 19 is that
something that
you two have been watching and have any
concerns about
with the mass protests um happening
across the country
well uh remy i wouldn't comment on the
process directly but
obviously any any situation where large
numbers of people gather together
where they can't uh maintain social
distancing of 1.5 metres
uh and when there's prolonged close
contact is going to lead to transmission
of
profit 19. right yeah i mean everybody
seems to be
very close together um but
you know it may be something that is a
concern going forward we've seen
hong kong protests going on for so long
before the pandemic started
clearly people with masks but they're
still very in close quarters
um so i guess the situation now is
evolving with coven 19.
um what do we know about the virus now
and
how long do you think it will stick
around for for spin if you could touch
on that
um yeah it's here to stay for a long
time unfortunately um
although um although uh in
the world now 20 to 30 of the population
may have been infected with covered 19
that still means there's
70 of the population is uninfected and
non-immune
uh in australia uh only 0.03
of the population has been infected so
there's an extremely large pool of
uh immune naive uh people who can still
be infected
if you think of a virus spreading
through the world like the fire
the fire needs fuel to burn and the fuel
here is
people who are not immune to covert 19
and there are still
billions of people in the world that are
not immune to code of 19. so
unfortunately it's going to be here for
a long time
and stephen how will that affect oh go
ahead jason
i was going to say stephen um what do
you think that will mean for
the way in which um we need to kind of
adapt this
uh to this new virus and its various
sort of
interesting characteristics that demand
uh things like physical distancing
to prevent i mean the impact of this is
just
unprecedented i've put together a whole
series of graphs on the shock to the
global economy
and each one you would say we've never
seen that this is unprecedented more
than ever before the
oecd is estimating two percent is
knocked off global gdp
growth uh global trade is forecast to
fall by 27
in the next quarter uh in australia the
treasury has forecast a fall of over 10
percent in the june quarter
statistical statistic is showing us this
massive shock in terms of unemployment
and economic impact more than we've ever
seen so
um we're at the beginning of a journey
here this is a marathon not a sprint
the the infectious disease period will
translate into an economic crisis and
already is
and there's a massive challenge for the
world to dig itself out of this position
you remember the world's economies the
world's advanced economies
are going into this situation with
record debt levels
uh record debt to gdp levels and record
low interest rates
so it's hard to to do a fix but
we're in for a massive amount of effort
to take the world from where it is today
to a healthy economy
and that's the next part of this journey
is we've started to sort of see the
epidemiology go towards the
field of economics and i think the two
are needed hand in hand for a while
uh we need to understand the economic
consequences of
health decisions and vice versa to try
and get the interplay right and give
give people the best chance of getting a
job but the masses of unemployment like
the us starter i'm looking at shows a
jump from 6.2
unemployment to 14.7 in the month of
april
which is a shocking outcome for millions
of americans who are now
for the first time registering for
unemployment benefits
yeah i think we've responded i'll go
ahead jason
it feels like we've continued to learn
so much about the virus over the last
five months
um the way it spreads the way we see so
many people who are asymptomatically
infected do you think there's much more
we still have to learn about this virus
or
do you think we've pretty much uh found
out at all there is to know
oh look there's an extraordinary amount
of uh
publishing data emerging in the
literature now but if you
look at hiv as a comparison we're really
a sort of
1981 or 1984 for hiv we're just at the
absolute beginning of understanding this
virus this huge amount still tonight i
mean
it's exciting and interesting it's also
worrying how little we still really
understand about the virus
the the number of publications uh sided
with covert
um covert in the title is something
hitting several thousand a week at the
moment
um there's a bit of chaff in there but
there's a lot of incredible information
coming out about transmission about
infectivity
about um about uh treatments about
vaccines
and every bit of knowledge is a step in
the right direction you have darkness
and fear and the treatment for that is
knowledge and understanding of the virus
and i am personally i've learnt so much
about this virus in the last
in the last few months when obviously it
wasn't on our radar this uh
in december 2019. so chris let's extend
our earlier conversation and i
i wanted to know from you is when's the
next covert 19 happening because
we're working with businesses small
businesses to large corporations that
are massively changing operations right
now
for the global period are they just
fixing things for covert 19 or is there
a covert 2025 occurred with 2030
tell us about the future i mean
unfortunately yes there will be further
pandemics and
in history we've had a severe major
fairly disastrous pandemic every 50
years on average for at least the last
500 years
and we've had smaller pandemics every 5
to ten years so
five roughly five years ago we had the
ebola pandemic in west africa
in 2009 we had the h1n1 swine flu
pandemic it's absolutely a question of
when
not if um i guess that moving forward
the thing we really have to focus is on
is this idea of disease x
we don't know which disease it's going
to be and i think um
uh sars2 coronavirus has really shown us
how important it is to prepare for the
unknown um
i think we're probably pretty well
positioned for an influenza pandemic
and we had drug treatments and vaccines
but we the vulnerability is another
disease x and whether it'll be another
coronavirus or a totally different
respiratory virus
or possibly another infection i don't
know and that's
where the focus needs to move in the
in the future we need to have obviously
a huge amount of understanding for this
outbreak but then we need to maintain
what i think is beginning to be called
the sort of the warm base
the warm base means you've got candidate
vaccines ready to go that it's not going
to take
two or three years to get them it's
going to take three to four months to
get them out you've got
a whole lot of broad spectrum antivirals
that are going to work against a lot of
different
viruses straight up with you know 25 new
antivirals by 2025 was another
theme i heard that we're all ready to go
that um
next time this definitely happens we can
jump in and really be
there in the first month or two of the
pandemic
um and ready to go and business models
that are resilient to these shocks in
the future so the university sector in
australia is well known to be taking a
massive hit as
overseas students are unable to arrive
and the fees the tuition fees aren't
flowing anymore
but they're not just fixing things i
think for covert 19. i think
based on the sort of advice we'll get
from health experts this is a new future
we're moving into as businesses redesign
the business model they should be asking
the question how is this resilient to a
future that looks like this this this
can't be
sort of like covert 19 itself is going
to go on for quite a while but then
there's future similar shocks
the other thing chrisman you were saying
earlier to me was about the flu
no one's catching the flu anymore yeah i
mean that is extraordinary vietnam
uh kareemi and jason really alongside
the social distancing and
border closures and so forth have had a
massive impact in australia on
preventing transmission of covert but in
fact influenza has largely disappeared
as well we have
almost zero cases of influenza like
whereas we'd normally just be going into
our
peak season now um the uh childhood
infection pertussis the vaccine
preventive disease pertussis normally
would be
around 1800 cases a year in australia
they've been fewer than 200 so far and
there's been a massive impact on the
social distancing of that
and it's very likely that a variety of
other respiratory infections will
not disappear but become way less
prominent as a result of the social
distancing that's occurred because
that really makes me think that this
does need to be the new normal
but a form of social distancing
infection control attention to hygiene
attention to hand hygiene
social etiquette around coughing and
tissues and
um and forms of social distancing is
going to be
the norm it's going to be absolutely
what we do um
kurumi i was just thinking really um
some of the asian uh
nations that were more affected by sars
have
hoped much better i think and have been
much more prepared for this because i
think there was a change in the social
norms around
socialism yeah yeah the mask use and
that the etiquette and and behavior
really was formed in in hong kong
and south korea last time around 17
years ago so
i i suspect you're probably feeling less
of a change in
cultural behavior in in tokyo certainly
than than this time around
yeah absolutely i think it it definitely
has an
impact the history of sars being in asia
we talk a lot about the mass culture
wars with
you know i grew up in the us where masks
are not the norm we're not the norm
before a covenant
so this idea that you know maybe asia
had a better handle of it before
we're more comfortable with it um the
social distance uh
culturally it may have had an impact
absolutely i mean we're
we were now seeing footage though of
beaches and restaurants and gyms
um living this new normal as you just
mentioned crispin
um and talking about how
you know post coping 19 or at least
coming out of lockdown
many places are adapting to new rules
about how to stay further apart on the
beaches like this footage in italian
riviera beaches
um they deny access to people if the
beach is fully booked so maybe you go
and you can't actually even enjoy the
beach
there are restaurants with bars that
have those
uh the floaties that you have to be on
so that they make sure that you are
further away from the
other guests um this is a restaurant in
france where
you're in these wine classes this is a
very creative way it's a social distance
with
with your dining partner or your date um
so kristen i know you said that there
will be a new normal
stephen in your opinion is this
something that will go on for a long
time
is this the new normal that will persist
or is this just temporary
until we find a vaccine what's your take
on this
no i think really the business as usual
is over um i think it is towards a new
normal
in many ways i mean the extent of the
economic shock is just
massive right we've never seen anything
like this as an analyst i could not have
predicted any of these results last year
or seen them as possible i think the um
evidence is we're moving into a
different sort of economy that's going
to operate and be different but then the
need for ongoing infectious disease
mitigation yeah
city planners of big cities like uh
tokyo or brisbane sydney
need to be thinking how do we make this
city work to mitigate infectious disease
risk
um and much more profoundly than we ever
have before but also
economic resilience so another fantastic
thing about japan uh
that we mentioned briefly on the last
interview was the unemployment rate
which i checked
on the oecd and they have something
called the harmonized rate of
unemployment which is consistent
across all oecd countries and japan
comes in at 2.5
unemployment compared to the us which is
now around about that 14
mark and the oecd average at six percent
so i think is chrisman's saying that
um some of these asian countries with
experience of sars and h1n1
um the previous infectious disease
outbreaks
they've actually been able to adjust
economically more efficiently to this
and i think that's the future we're
moving towards if you are in a large
corporation and you're a head
strategic planner all of a sudden the
infectious disease risk
is there in terms of how you structure
your organization's activity from supply
chains changing
through how your workforce has managed
your ability to telework
the other big shift that we're picking
up massively is the the growth of the
digital economy sector the
you know united nations estimates 1.2
billion students across the world are
studying
online uh at some point or studying
remotely many of
them are online teleworking inspiration
tele health is off the charts
online entertainment online retail all
these aspects of the econ
and our digital tech sector companies
are going counter trend
they're growing really fast and on the
asx i haven't studied other
world markets but the iss is showing
really strong rebound for digital tech
sector companies whereas the general
market is moving up gradually but
digital tech sectors going about three
times faster so
it's it's like i think technology is
playing a role in the restructure here
um crispin you're an infectious diseases
doctor you would have
asked many of the same reports that i've
seen predicting
this sort of pandemic does it surprise
you
just how badly prepared we were for what
we knew
would be you know something that was in
our future
um it's amazing how
how severe this pandemic has been it's
extraordinary it's unprecedented really
there's nothing like it until you go
back to 1918 and look at the
catastrophic spanish fleet pandemic
really yeah i um
i mean if any of us online here had been
asked that we'd be
locked down that the borders in
australia would be shut that you
couldn't take an international holiday
which you think you'd be ridiculous but
of course this has been predicted
um we had a we had a trial run with sars
one
um which was really a near miss in
retrospect like we had a really good
trial run and um we learned a lot from
that
and um obviously the australian response
has been
strong and based on a lot of the
learnings from sars but it
in retrospect does seem to be a fairly
big lost opportunity in terms of things
like vaccine development and drug
treatment
and and so forth um as i'm sure you're
aware
sars one and size two current advice the
current one are genetically quite
similar they're
really not much difference and a lot of
the technology innovation that
could have been put in place there would
be really really helpful right now may
have brought us a precious few extra
months potentially in terms of vaccines
drug therapy
lessons about social distancing
infection control in hospitals
personal protective use equipment
stockpiling and that sort of thing so
um i mean i i think um pandemics are
absolutely the norm
and they're not going anywhere and i
guess um the thing is now to make sure
that this never happens again
moving forward one of the things i took
from the spanish flu actually 1918-19
spanish food was followed by the 19 2021
depression uh where unemployment
spiraled the dow jones crashed
it was an economic depression worldwide
sometimes called the the forgotten
depression because people focus on the
30s
but what was interesting in 1922 to 1929
we had what's called the roaring 20s
where economic growth really picked up
in fact gdp growth rates were roughly
double
what they are compared to long-term
averages over that period
and it took us right up to the 1930s
where speculation on wall street led to
another bubble and crash but during that
decade there of the 1920s and roaring
20s things went really well
and i think you know that in my work
i've been interested about
what pathways we follow out of here and
why some researchers from university of
adelaide
and columbia university new york uh
macroeconomists
have said that the main thing that
happened was electricity as a general
purpose technology was widely deployed
throughout that so the shock to the
system
which was spanish flu with an economic
shock created space for
technological innovation which at the
time was electricity which led to
productivity uplift
and a whole lot of positive outcomes so
part of me is hopeful towards a positive
future of the economic rebound from this
situation
is uh we see general-purpose
technologies like artificial
intelligence genetics
digital technologies more broadly we can
kind of see evidence of their uptake in
use and i think
given the the record debt levels we are
low interest rates
governments don't have much room to move
on fiscal stimulus or monetary policy
they may turn towards productivity
uplift and
technology technology enablement um
could be our way through
and uh and that technology enablement is
also what helps us mitigate
infectious disease risk yeah stefan
would agree that really that
the solutions to making sure that never
happens again are primarily innovative
biotechnology that's what's going to
save today
um i'm talking vaccines drug therapy
better diagnostics and
you know really novel ways of
surveilling for infectious diseases so
this great idea of
analyzing the city's entire sewage
samples for
viruses to pick out breaks in the sewage
before we even
detect human cases or another idea is to
uh
sample the bilge tanks of air lines and
see if we can detect viruses in the
build states and you're going to get
much quicker intelligence about the
outbreak next time
i'm sure you've seen all the modeling
that shows that really for every week
that you respond to a
pandemic with exponential growth
potential you save
thousands and thousands of cases really
so rapid response is just
critical technology biotechnology is
what will get us there
absolutely do you think do you think um
i think that our personal
information has to be we have to have a
different view
on what is sort of private and what is
confidential if if
our if our fecal material is going to be
sampled on our airplane do we have to
sort of
expect that um they're going forward
we're going to have to
uh for our own health security being
much more amenable to
people knowing more about us look
i work in the area of data and digital
and i think privacy is something that
needs more attention a lot of the
innovations that are really beneficial
to us
are held back due to privacy concerns
now some of that is very legitimate
you've got to be careful with people's
privacy people can be really harmed
through a breach of their privacy
but at the same time there's a lot of
stuff that doesn't risk your privacy
that is really beneficial to you and i
think infectious disease control
yes being able to track and monitor and
know where people are can really help
if and with the strong provider if we're
absolutely sure that that
information that product information
about your location behavioral patterns
is kept
private and secure and i think it can be
again science and technology solutions
are needed to do this
as we move into the world of artificial
intelligence the ability to breach your
privacy is greater than ever before
there's a lot of bad players out there
who are attempting to do it on a regular
basis
but there's also some sort of you know
bizarre stuff around privacy
people being hyper ultra sensitive to it
when their risks aren't that great so as
we looked at artificial intelligence in
healthcare
we found a lot of life-saving
interventions weren't going ahead
because of privacy concerns and
uncertainty by
healthcare professionals about what was
okay and wasn't around data privacy
so i don't know
that in general people with infectious
diseases have a very strong need for
privacy
i've learned that again the hard way
from hiv but the moment you start
breaching people's privacy
the moment you make testing compulsory
rather than voluntary the wheels fall
off
um you need people to be honest and
frank and you need to incentivize
testing if you if you breach people's
privacy
if you force people to have tests and if
you discriminate against people
because of their infectious diseases
that is hiv being a really strong point
in this you worsen the epidemic
more people get infected the more people
die so um
in terms of those sort of math sampling
i wouldn't be suggesting you'd be
that they wouldn't they wouldn't
identify who was sitting on the toilet
in the plane
um it'd be everyone on the plane but um
yeah it's probably the other way you
want people to be tested as much as
possible and privacy is the most
important part of that now
most people are pretty happy to share
their information to help society
it's only a minority that are worried
about sharing information but i guess
the things they worry about is having
their
pathology results flashed all over the
media or um or uh
i identified uh as part of an outbreak
and then being hounded and
that's the worst thing you can do to
reduce testing and drive people
underground
all right definitely definitely a tricky
balance there um so just as a reminder
for everybody joining us
now on this broadcast please ask us your
questions live and i'll do my best to
get you the answers
from our experts today throughout the
broadcast okay um
now i want to go on to touch on
something that affects
many of us it's working from home
um i think with the quarantine
it's affected so many of us all over the
world a few months ago my team in hong
kong actually showed us their work from
home situation
so let's see this video that we put
together here's what it's been like for
them
[Music]
oh my god listen to that
yeah i need yoga today i prefer to be
in the office nicely
[Music]
it's just me and my couch and my laptop
so
looking like this working and then
um it's hard on my neck i'm always
looking down
i miss um just that human interaction
with my colleagues i find that really
important
as i'm sitting here trying to edit a
video um millie will be bringing me a
toy
or she'll be like rolling in front of me
purring in a way that's one of the best
scenes of working from homes i get to
spend a lot of time with them
i pretty much can work anywhere um as
long as i have my laptop at wi-fi or
data i can be sitting at a cafe here
in sydney or anywhere else in the world
so
that's a great thing i can just roll out
of bed and start working
i don't have to change out my pajamas
yeah i'm
i'm always in pajamas every day
i am always wearing a face mask i've
plants
i've plant i've been tending to my
plants i have a lot of avocado plants
it's hard being a plant mom you know i
get to hang out with my dog bowie this
is bowie
our little edit helper
[Music]
yoga and meditation for me have been
absolutely
key to staying safe making lots of green
smoothies
cheers cooking a lot i'm also going to
the gym
a lot more and i'm doing super exciting
things now
i am going to search for some blue paper
because i'm down to
two year olds in my house and yet
still no loot paper
[Music]
yeah so we see some pros and cons there
of working from home
stefan we've talked about this briefly
before but let's talk about how the
pandemic has changed the way we work
and maybe preferences for where we live
is this something that we will see
persist
is work from home gonna be a new option
for many many companies
for many workers around the world
well in australia prior to covert 19
around 30
of all employed persons uh regularly
work from their home in their main job
or business
and it was definitely on an upward
trajectory where we're at now i'd say
the vast majority i've actually been
searching for a
reliable statistic on this i can't find
it but practically everyone i know and
in my team we're all
working from home are we going to go
back again very few of the people i work
with have yet done it
there are some benefits being reported
as well as the sort of downsides of
doing it but
one of which is commute times the
average commute time for a brisbane
resident to work is 60 minutes one way
it's a
probably a bit over that in sydney and
closer to one and a half hours i think
in sydney's average commute time now
so people are getting quite a lot of
time back in their day and that's that's
one aspect of the shift
but ultimately i think those workforces
in companies where
people could easily switch to work from
home again they were mostly tech sector
companies that did it early quickly and
smoothly because of the nature of work
did a lot better and it's an important
picking up on the concepts of economic
resilience to future disease risk
the ability to shift work into a
telework environment is a key aspect the
fact that i can keep earning money
during this by teleworking is really
important so i think it's going to
expand
and i don't think we're going back to
normal i think there will be a bit of a
return to office but a lot of people
will stay working from home and
maybe we start to see some changes in
real estate too maybe people start
looking for those seat change
tree change options there's a little bit
of evidence too early to save a little
bit of evidence that may be occurring as
well
for you i mean clearly as a physician uh
working from home
uh full-time isn't really an option how
but how is the pan am i gonna change the
way
people like you work uh are we
essentially can't really work from home
but our patients are voting with their
feet and staying at home
and using telemedicine to attend their
clinical appointment but
also just thinking i haven't actually
seen a face-to-face outpatient for the
last two weeks because it's all been
video conferenced
um patients actually really prefer it
they don't have to pay for parking at
the hospital
they don't want to come and get exposed
to infectious diseases
uh just you know for a routine medical
visit and i think
healthcare is going to be dramatically
transformed by this and really in
embracing video conferencing
telemedicine um
it'll mean huge access back gains for
people in rural and remote locations who
can't access city specialists that's
going to change forever i have no desire
to go back to the old days of the full
waiting room of people copying all of
each other driving for an hour to get
here and
there are only benefits i really see
there are obviously exceptions when you
need to examine a patient and perform a
procedure but that's
the minority of work i think these days
and i think kelly madison is really
going to
take over my my work from home day now
means a mountain bike ride with my son
in the morning up now kotha because i've
got time i don't have to rush to
to work and then another ride in the
evening with my daughter uh
to down the bikeway to a place called
rocks riverside
and it's been fantastic you know my the
main risk to my health is the open
access fridge i'm like the cafe i don't
have to pay any money for it
you know i i think you know i think i
might need to put a swipe credit card on
it or something
but um there's a lot of benefits to me
and um i think some of the unintended
benefits of telemedicine is that you're
in the patient's home
they can go to the drug cupboard and
show you the medications they're on and
then you can
look at the staircase that they might
fall down and then their
husband or wife jumps in and gives you
an update on how they think they're
going it's a much more real uh
interaction than the people coming into
the into the hospital and
it's much more balanced i think it's a
useful kick along for telehealth in that
it's it's been there in health i mean
you'll know more chris but it's been
there in health for quite a while it
hasn't been really significant uptake
until now i'm looking at a data set of
medicare uh items
claimed on telehealth and it just shoots
up in
in actually february then to march and
april and
i think this is actually going to be
pretty critical for the world to deal
with unsustainable healthcare
expenditure growth so
in australia as per a lot of the oecd
healthcare expenditures just growing way
faster than gdp
we can't afford for the bills today let
alone the future
and i think telehealth is an important
part of the solution that brings those
costs down not delivering the
same quality of service but yeah
chrisman that's interesting to hear how
you can have a component obviously
we've learned in the last few months
that there's obviously a lot of very low
value care that we deliver in healthcare
that just can stop altogether you just
don't need to do it anymore
um uh you know people uh
are voting with their feet to not engage
in things that actually aren't very
useful we just don't have to go back to
doing them again
let's save a lot of do you money it
would be able to be
any uh discernible difference in um
things like hospital
uh healthcare associated infections with
keeping fewer people out uh yeah the
more the less you meet
people around the less chance they have
to spread infections like antibiotic
resistant infections and so forth
um i don't know if you've seen uh jason
in the media really reports of decreased
antibiotic use by 50 to 50 percent in
the states for example um
there's just been a dramatic decrease in
unnecessary antibiotic prescriptions
something you know i'm very interested
and worried about
and that's going to have huge beneficial
flow on effects
the other thing we're seeing i guess is
better connections with community
pharmacy and community
community general practitioners now much
better linkages with primary care
a whole lot of conditions that maybe
were seen to be specialist medicine
previously like hepatitis c treatment
that can actually be done
really well in primary care by gp just
with a
phone call or a video link for
specialists is required
um and again i just can't emphasize
enough how important that is for rural
and remote people
uh who really are accessing some
healthcare for the first time so
um patients in the far rural areas of
queensland can now do a stress test for
a cardiac condition
monitored on a video camera from
brisbane with all of the tests and
things done and it
saves them a round trip and it speeds up
their
uh process of diagnosis by at least six
weeks so that's wonderful really no
downside
okay um something i do want to touch on
before we go because we are coming up on
35 minutes um many coming out of the
lockdown
they're itching to go see family or
travel including myself i've been
wanting to go back to new york to see my
parents
american airlines has drawn criticism
from a passenger who said she never felt
so unsafe on board a flight from fresno
to dallas this happened on may 17th
here's the video take a look
so overcrowded
so short clip there but we can't see
that it looks
packed and this was on may 17th so
kristen will there be a safe way to
travel in an airplane
in a pre-vaccine era and what kind of
precautions will be needed to keep
everybody
safe as much as possible yeah yes yes
that will look at it
i can understand why people would be
very worried about this but it is
interesting to say that really the
with some exceptions there hasn't been
widespread evidence of transmission of
coronavirus
in in flights it hasn't it's a partial
part of the problem i think there are
some reasons why that is the
the laminar air flowing in planes
through hepa filters means that you're
not freezing everyone's
air right across the plane the fact that
everyone's facing in the same direction
they're not
talking and fitting potentially into
each other's faces
most flights are pretty short as well so
i think with all of these things with
returning back to work returning back to
business we've got to not look at the
even the economics or the passion and
emotion it's got to look at the science
and see where transmission is happening
we
have incredibly large amounts of
information on where transmissions
occurring i have to say really
airlines have not been a prominent
feature i know that there are some
exceptions but really they're not
accounting for the vast majority of
transmission that's at home
in people's homes it's at um it's a
uh in in close cramped environments
sometimes with the service of alcohol at
a face-to-face
conversation for hours on end and that's
that's where the where the money is with
with airline travel i think there are
things that we need to
learn and things that we can do to make
it even safer that'd be a lot of things
around cleaning
hygiene um how the planes are loaded and
unloaded and how people interact with
before and after the flight and then
whether there needs to be considerations
for really a
prolonged flight so maybe if you're
flying from tokyo to new york the risk
is quite a bit bigger than if i'm
flying from brisbane to sydney and
building that sort of concept into it as
well the duration of the flight might be
quite relevant as well
um but i'd be hopeful that you can visit
your parents
uh prior to a vaccine being developed i
think that's
that's realistic and this fantastic idea
of travel bubbles with people traveling
from
low prevalence country two low
prevalence countries in a bubble is a
really good one and i think there's a
lot of sense to it
on average have fallen by eight point
five percent so the average
length in kilometers the people fly has
gone down 8.5
so the flying public are gradually
returning but there's a big drop
in how far they're flying
chrisman i just wanted to ask you a
little bit more about vaccines um
clearly they're being accelerated in
their
development um what do you think the
best uh
uh outcome would be in terms of the
durability of
of any immune response to a vaccine are
we likely to
need to have a booster shot at least
once a year what how do you see that
playing out
i think that's a really good question
jason and i guess so there was a survey
of infectious diseases
specialists in australia last week about
people's prospects for the vaccine and
we got it back one one third of people
thought a one dose for a lifetime would
be enough
one-third thought that you'd have to
have a yearly dose and one-third thought
the vaccine wouldn't work so it was
pretty
pretty hard to draw any conclusions i'm
bullish about a vaccine i think
uh the progress that's being made by
universities and organizations around
the world in vaccine development it's
really exciting
and there are over 100 vaccines in
in development um 176 at last count i
believe
using a variety of different strategies
it's really clever it's not just one
strategy for all 176 vaccines there are
whole cell inactivated vaccines there
are attenuated vaccines there are these
subunit vaccines and the really excited
exciting adenovirus vectored rna
vaccines which are very easy to mass
produce and
um the prospects are looking great i
have to say um organizations like the
university of queensland and professor
paul young who have a
strong candidate vaccine well into
production now there
there are strong preclinical evidence of
strong immune responses in fact
the antibody responses the neutralizing
antibody responses with the vaccines are
way
stronger than actual infection which is
really promising
there are now successful animal
challenge studies you
vaccinate um rhesus monkeys and ferrets
and the exposed coronavirus they do not
become sick with it
and now thousands of of uh humans have
received vaccines
in trials uh in in several countries now
we don't know if they work just yet but
there certainly hasn't been like a
disastrous
adverse effect or some some problem with
it
accentuation of viral infection because
of the vaccine there's been it hasn't
been blown out of the water
and i think it's really promising
therefore that this is going to be a
vaccine
preventable disease within a year or so
you've probably also
seen that uh in australia and the uk and
the states and elsewhere there's this
great idea of ramping up vaccine
production now
stefan and the csiro are really a big
part of that that by the time the
clinical trials are finished maybe in
september
there'll already be hundreds of
thousands of doses ready to go as well
which is great so i think it's
really likely that we'll have a vaccine
for this and that that
we'll be seeing that roll out at the end
of this year
to what extent do you think that that is
going to be crucial for resuming
international travel for example
i mean it would be the icing on the cake
i don't think a vaccine is going to be a
solution uh just by itself uh for a
variety of reasons one will be
how equitably that can be distributed
through the world but it needs to be
done
based on people's need and risk not
based on their ability to pay for it
um it depends on how um
how good the vaccine is like you're
living involved will one dose be enough
will you need booster doses
um uh will there be like lifelong
immunity or not that's really relevant
um but it'll be part of it it'll be an
important part of it but it won't be the
total solution all right we got some
great answers now we're gonna take some
questions from
our audience here is the first one
how many deaths are actually from the
virus i think we're
intentionally being misled so some
question on the data
and whether the numbers are accurate and
true i can take that one if you like and
i guess um
uh in australia we're in a very
uh fortunate position of practically
having 102
debt from coronavirus but as a result
the data is very strong in australia
we're very confident that we're
recording almost all of the deaths
in most countries particularly those are
overwhelmed there is no possibility that
uh there's an accurate accurate count
unfortunately
really relies on a positive swab a
positive
test and and in many many countries in
the world
the the testing is just not available uh
in the way it is in australia
um i think the best thing to look at is
its excess mortality and i'm sure you've
seen
uh studies from europe usa
from asia many countries doing a huge
increase in
mortality not necessarily attributed to
coronavirus infections
the thing i think you've got to look out
for in country data is if there's a very
close proximity between
the number of tested positive and the
number of deaths you've got to suspect
there's going to be a huge
um unrecognized problem in that country
so there are countries i think where
they
i won't name the country but there is
one country where there have been 16 000
cases and something like two or three
thousand deaths and it clearly shows
that they're just not
testing enough and that'll be a gross
underestimate
in ebola in africa in h1n109 we didn't
really find out the true
uh mortality for several years
afterwards and it was based on excess
mortality it will be way
higher than than 380 thousand to be way
higher than the numbers now
sadly there's also the second wave of
death
of death and and illness caused by
people's inability to
inability to access care and i think
stefan you've also mentioned
the the wave of human misery that's
going to be precipitated by the
recession and the economic aspect
yeah i mean unemployment has been
studied by epidemiologists as well and
it has a higher death rate so long-term
unemployment is about 1.3 times
the standard mortality rate compared to
not being long-term unemployed so
i guess if that is connected to it then
that is part of it as well
um cause and effect can be debated but
we
we shouldn't underestimate the human
health psychological and
physical of unemployment it's terrible
okay yeah uh we have another question
here
let's go on to the next one uh how can
we really enjoy life
in the new normal happy hour on zoom is
not so great
ditto for concerts in fortnite so i
guess this is talking
about maybe uh stephanie can talk to
this a little bit
it's an interesting one i mean one thing
we didn't mention in the conversation is
some of the
amazingly beautiful things that have
happened in this world during kerber 19
one of which is a 17
decrease in greenhouse gas emissions
that was reported in a nature paper
since we last spoke grooming
and i think it's just in a world where
we've seen greenhouse gas emissions
going up and up it's dropped for the
first time
decreased traffic accidents in australia
we've seen an april 25
reduction in road mortality a uc
california
uc davis california study looks at a 50
decrease in fatal and injury crash rates
on their highways
some really good stuff has been going on
during the covert lockdown as the
question is more about as we go beyond
into this new normal and how can life be
any fun
there are ways we can find it i mean i
think let's look at a lot of
ways people's lives have been enriched
during this time they say in venice
they can see the fish in the water in
india they can see the himalayas in
in brisbane from mount cuthur i can see
out to the airport in morton island and
stradbroke because the air quality is
getting better
some things are getting better and i
suspect aspects of people's
relationships better a hell of a lot of
mums and dads are out on the trails of
malcuthu and on the bikeways with their
kids
enjoying each other's time i think we
will find a way
and we need to get all the balancing
done correctly we can't have no human
contact we've still got to
live life and have fun but we try and as
kristen says let's look at the science
where we're taking huge risks and i
think the pandemic has shown us where
there are huge risks
which may not be all that fun as well
have uh
which we can avoid and then let's put
the weight where things are good but
let's also look at the really beautiful
things that have happened to humanity
during the last few months amongst all
the suffering as well we've learned
about what's possible it'd be a tragedy
to lose it
yeah as brothers stefan and i have been
able to connect
really well in the last few months you
know as you know the
restrictions so is that an upside or a
downside
um we'll wait for that later but i mean
i i think
the the opportunity i've had to connect
with family to spend time with my boys
riding a biker in the local park is
lovely
actually the restrictions in queensland
are easing up this weekend
there's a part of me that's a bit
worried about it actually the weekend
suddenly seems to be much more full of
social activities and i'm not going to
miss some i'm going to miss aspects of
this obviously there are things i don't
uh
miss at all but uh there are things i'm
going to use we've discovered what a
beautiful region we live in right around
here you know all the great things you
can do within a
uh you know 50 or 100 kilometer drive
from your house is actually fantastic
and i've
you know i met neighbors and people that
i wouldn't have connected with so there
is a
upside to it i've been on a plane for
work since the first
of january so that to me is just being
beautiful
just go over this once though we can do
the fun stuff that's safe we just have
to
restrict the stuff that's really
dangerous there's a lot of evidence now
that really
outdoor settings seem to be way safer
way way safer there's much
more opportunity for social distancing
there's much more air clearance
uv light is a um really effective
antiviral and they're
very little evidence of transmission and
outdoor areas so
let's see yeah go with the science and
if we can continue to confirm low
transmission
outdoors let's do more alfresco uh
dining
things outside you know have have uh
memorial masses and funerals in the in
in nature you know that that's what
we've got to learn and there's a whole
lot of good stuff that we can say
instead of sitting in giant plastic wine
glasses those two people could be
uh you know a vignette in the field
having a glass of wine there are there
are i mean i'm not saying that's a bad
thing that they're doing but there are
different ways
i don't know about the way they're
drinking beer at that pub that you just
seem to
find it fun for about 15 minutes but
that wouldn't work for me really
okay so maybe more hiking and camping
this summer huh
okay well i think that was a great way
to end so that wraps things up for us
here thank you so much our special
guests
uh brothers the haikovich brothers
stefan from csiro data61 insights and
crispin from australia's largest
hospital
you